you
gilli wibble thank you for the
subscription with twitch Prime those of
you who may be subscribing and donating
and throwing bits and such I'll be sure
to address that towards the end but for
now Lee chest titled arena 5 let's see
the the master at work here dr. drunken
Stein against night king 96 oh and I
should quickly get rid of the sound here
all right
so an open an open D file and a and
imbalance oh did he already calculate
that that he's going to get the rook in
the corner now if the knight moves the
knight can be rescued so White's trying
to still keep this guy under control
both bishops are now under fire and up
upon Carlsen and look at he's not he's
not ready to take the knight just yet
because black could go ahead and take
the pawn on c2 really holding off on
scooping the knight up stuck around
there for quite a bit so imbalance
structurally boatload of pawns and the
superior minor piece excellent stability
for the bishop a perfect home cannot be
challenged rook behind the pond improve
the King scare the night away and then
push I don't think there's anything
fancy with a with the night here Knight
here King here and then March it already
start marching at this point get the
pawn here the bishop is an excellent
supporter
Knight is under control let's see how to
convert this he uh he's up just a little
bit on the clock about 10 seconds yeah
King this guy is ready to go as well
King here King c6 would have been strong
oh that's a big blunder okay well just
needs to sack the the bishop for the
night but actually they may still play
on night versus Bishop that was a big
blunder losing a full Brooke there and
another fork this night is tricky and
this is winning now for night king whoa
1.5 is he gonna be able to pull it off I
believe you will oh the Queen was free
just then he's trying to burn the time
he's not going for me that's a good
strategy
no need to go for me when you could
rattle off a bunch of free moves and and
not the best start for the doc who is in
140 third place ooh that Knight is extra
tricky okay
ah man King's Indian or carl-henric to
e8 getting out of a pin
a little bit of a delay they're not sure
what the scoop was okay
strong pawn on d5 is challenged bishops
post is challenged launching the
queenside pawns d5 is a sensitive point
for black a little bit of space for
black on the Queen side light square
bishop exchange would mean that the
knight would have a wonderful square on
c4 hopping in there now there is no b3
so down upon his Carlsen but has
excellent pieces the night in the rook
capturing what the knight would go into
an awkward pin this bishop is stable
black is now better having already a
flight Square and the more active rook
cannot be defended because of main so
let's see if he can convert this this is
national master doom fist pretty new
player I don't think I've played no from
Nigeria apparently okay anyhow lateral
defence is the thing to take away from
this one not going on the same file
these guys can get marching the rook is
very good here no actually this is
pretty instructive notice there's not
this quick move to give a check instead
he's gonna form a bit of a wall and only
then come up here actually I mean you
can continue to improve the King ah
that's a nice one checking when the
Kings Kings here now you'll be able to
go with check and then promote so he
will be getting this one slightly down
on time in fact ba da he's ready to pick
up the rook next and we have it nice
alright so he is he's got the first one
still plenty of time coming up the Rings
and jumped up there to 70s fifth place
and he's playing against mr. green Oh
eight who did not play d5 so I think
that's a slip now this pawn is a giant
thorn compromising really the whole
black Queen side preparation for a dark
Barry Bishop exchange the dark squares
are pretty weak and blacks camp this is
actually that was actually a move a
Knight takes pawn takes the rook would
have been trapped no fancy discoveries
huh oh that's a sharp move on takes
Bishop takes with the skewer and now we
have a killer bee a Pinter Oni on the
Queen she's a goner and it's not too
much more to speak of with this one yeah
just a quick resign for mr. green Oh
eight so oh let me let me jump over real
quick these are these are standings
penguin is in there under the original
handle no no clever tactic this time
penguin is in there with 13 and is on
fire
all right Baba Ramdev next opponent
let's see what we get here all right
looking at the f4 square the knight is
gonna go there here we go good
coordination between structure and
Bishop and open G file here we go
through 'kz h3 is under fire how do you
defend that the knight drum drops back
home yeah but now this you defend h3 but
you know you cannot so easily contest
the G file so this is a bit
uncomfortable or white yes trying to pry
away this is a weak square maybe the
Queen could slither on in but I expect
something like this no no a sacker oniy
giving up the bishop to tear open the
structure and the Queen is now a goner
no no need for this this positional
approach you got to be a little bit
careful Carlsen no here and then here
this is the King gonna be in a little
bit of hot water I think he's feeling
like he's in some hot water with this
pause now under 30 seconds the Kings are
gonna have to bolt
I think this rook is going to be picked
up the rooks can get here here and this
rook is gonna fall mmm and in the end
white is up a minor
ouch okay mmm very close to me it has
Perpetua
who wants it as you want perpetual or
does he want more he wants more once
more but now White has good coordination
gonna slip away 15 seconds apiece okay
Queen gonna get active the king has
found safe haven oh I don't know how
safe it is and it's a bullet race and
Carlson is at the eight second mark oh
and there goes the Queen he should be
able to pull this one off
baba yeah
another resigned by Carlson and okay a
fast paring Rain Man next opponent arc
of 50s in first with 16 fire penguin
also with 16 no fire Rain Man this guy
is very good at counting toothpicks
where's Carlson huh uh-oh he didn't move
connection issue
oh what's that about maybe he did not
want to face the rain man hello Andy is
Yoda in the chat these are the standings
I'm not sure what the scoop is with Carl
some of you in the chat are saying rage
quit another saying his stream is acting
weird I'm thinking it's the latter
we'll see how about we jump into another
game while we wait and this is probably
a good guy to check out let's uh let's
go here no no no no no no no we got a
game he's back in there just a little
bit of a hiccup or are we gonna have
another time oh no because if he's
disconnected he's still gonna get know
he's here forget all that we have a
caro-kann on board against nm Horrible's
Oh the Bronstein Larsson variation of
the Carroll solid white structure okay
this is being challenged with the e5
there is a gap now an f5 one of the most
sensitive points in blacks camp but the
King is not a
so queens are now gone this is this is
good news for black he's now up upon as
well and should be converting this right
bishop pair and night that's kind of out
of bounds supporting the bishop soon
looking to coordinate on f2 doubling up
on the e on the D file soon enough this
pawn will fall and this guy will run
yeah you could just pick them up
probably with the Bishop rook takes
there would be an exchange and then here
though you could follow up with rook to
D to anyhow Bishop pair up upon passer
check first Bishop back with tempo I
like that this guy is falling and these
this is this is too easy at this point I
believe the a pond yeah white goes ahead
and throws in the towel black up upon
bishop pair fast a pond so where we have
been standings ARCA flawless jungle
Viking is also flawless 20 with fire
boat distinctive a cm candidate master
or Carlsen plenty of time remaining in
this one let's see we get whoa some
serious early problems will they be
corrected another non mover Carlsen
something's going on with his internet
hmm okay hopefully he get that situated
fast because these guys are off to a
blazing start 280 are in here you can
certainly come back that is for sure
um I was a stick around here I don't I
don't want to jump away the last time it
happened he did get a fairly fast
pairing we'll see I'm looking at the
chat here so some of you here in the
twitch chat are saying that it's the
Comcast gambit is that
sure uh we'll see he is still not in a
game maybe we could maybe we could go
ahead and jump over to the penguin crazy
penguin while Carlson tries to get
things situated yeah let's go there
penguin Carlson okay let's let's see
what the crazy penguin is so no no oh
there's this must have been a blunder
here huh no not quite
okay material is balanced something may
soon be lost you support it though this
guy isn't a gun not going anywhere so
this is an excellent structure you take
with the rook or the night okay he wants
the file and he's going to support f4
now jumps right into the seventh
maintain the structure okay challenging
the knight better pieces for why all
them are better and down on the clock
super fast penguin not too often Lee see
him behind on the clock when he only
neat old Knights actually dead hmm fancy
in takes Knight pawn takes rook here
Bishop f8 in this bishop will fall under
10 seconds that shoot up a ton of time
but he's super quick six seconds can he
come back I'm not familiar with this
player wgm 13 seconds two three let's
see 2.7 seconds it's not quite at a
point where you could pre move out but
I've seen him rattle ah okay this is
this is a point where you could pre move
out when you see how far there there's a
four point eight eight the slippery
penguin is going to win point five eight
point one why did it even go down that
far Oh point one three and time out for
team black
okay Carlson point Carlson's playing
okay and where we at here Carlson is
down on time and has just one okay oh
man okay let's let's get things straight
here this is where I want to be these
are the standings and Carlson is
apparently back up and running in 79th
place I actually don't mind seeing those
a couple hiccups early on it makes for
an interesting you know could he come
back we're gonna see all right not their
first time playing first time playing in
this tournament
anyhow open e file it's a piece play
position this Knight really wants to
move so the bishop can see it's a little
bit of space for white clearing the way
for the bishop that's a pretty
inconvenient move these bishops are
really strong for black nice position
for black I like I like blacks position
to be careful that this pawn doesn't
move rook here ecigs is strong east six
is in there so now the white rooks are
brought to life both sides have very
active rooks huh that's a nice
continuation a structural damage some
structural damage on the Queen side now
wins upon black has a more active rook
there is a check on EA but it is not
mate can't step up to defend now the
bishops there to defend though on
outside past one so consolidate first
this guy is secure the bishop secures
the White King very well the King side
structure very well trying to get active
gonna be good home for the bishop a
counter attacking against the bishop on
East h7 check offering a rook exchange
very sensible up now two pawns
Carlsen and eight seconds on the clock
easy to get a lot of fast moves in here
not too long off from being able to pre
move this one out constantly questioning
the king he's getting flushed back and
just keep on marching
this guy's a long way off from posing
any serious threat to white
he's just gonna push on through just
trying to divert the bishop from
defending f6 five point eight seconds
yep and he's pushing on through Bishop
here followed up with a promotion check
pick up the pawn and then go hunting
it's just a time out
all right where do we stand ARCA has
slipped up twenty eight with fire
twenty-six penguin twenty five MSB to
who also competed in the last tournament
or I think me me the first that was MSB
twos first time competing in the title
Dorina
all right back in the ring is Carlson
and he does have a move in this time
around playing against doctor the big
boss running up with a crazy H pawn some
dent in a king side structure this
brings into question the black Kings
home where's a safe haven now that
there's no heart on the Kings side no
heart on either side reeling in a
beautiful square on c5 the knight is
jumping on in there where to go with the
king it's kind of scary nights on the
rim not grim here once you get g4 in oh
[Music]
no
so once the G file opposite color
bishops hmm I think white would have
liked to have it a little bit different
still preferred for white this is a nice
shelter but you know what this too is
not a bad structure either how do you
get at the black King meanwhile black is
actually coming back with these last
handful of moves getting some play along
the G file ah an exchange sacrifice
trying to break this structure down but
hmm is there something timely with a six
and then maybe targeting the c7 point
may try for that no black seems to be a
little bit faster white has to go on the
defensive and the king is returning but
the a pond is past let's not forget
about this white also has a nice secure
King and this structure really does a
number on both rooks
rizzoli exchanging the peace giving the
exchange back mmm what does black have
here yeah take here there might be this
stuff black is getting some action
against the white king 15 seconds of
peace call it the doctor Big Boss what
is he thinking about
okay I was thinking maybe it was a there
was a mate threat on a1 whoo
now the kink it made me find safe ground
right here the rook defends very nice
seven seconds for black Queen exchange
and run this pawn can he be stopped no
not so fast the king is there in time
also Big Time edge for white and now
just winning yeah clean unseen this is
gonna be a w-4 Carlsen he now steps up
to what not on the first page 32 arc of
50 ali reza has now morphed into a GM
since the last tournament officially i
am ali reza for lee chest titled arena
for dmitri IM next opponent King side
fiend kettle some Marat Marat see bind
d5 is in in one stroke and let's see how
the the center changes strong point on
d5 strong point on e5 is being
undermined with f6 yeah light square
bishop exchange on board a 6 is
sensitive it is backward this Knight
moves this month this little jump in so
these guys are on to stand off some
pressure on b2 pressure on the center
the rook is gonna stay active on c4 no
in exchange the Knights gonna hop on in
there I guess no very nice the queen is
trying to coordinate with the night that
white that's why the Queen stays on this
diagonal meanwhile this pawn is running
and there's an idea of Bishop to d4
Queen a d4 as well the knight could
always get the exchange back what just
happened there oh the rook fell his
thinking the Knights just gonna jump in
we got the rook was under fire anyhow
resignation for team light Carlsen got
that one baba ramdev next opponent let's
see if Carlsen can get him back lost the
first one was that the one no thinking
that was the one where his opponent
went on a spree with forks okay
London system in this one see oh that's
a mouse slip I believe he meant a
capture on d4 then I think there would
have been a problem on c5 if black
wasn't timely anyhow it's right here to
capture and be on the Queen the Queen
can recapture to be careful about this
diagonal pressure on g2 can't go too far
all right no worries here on the g2
point anymore no bishop around even on
the clock both sides with a flight
square a little bit of well a majority
for white on the Queen side so I would
like to get these guys rolling first
improving the night there was a threat
ninth c6 with the fork so some activity
now Queen's are gone past a pond and
pick up the f7 pond with a knight keep
the real here defending to be trick you
know I have to be careful because the
tricky Knights you have to be tricky
because of the Knights careful here here
and then get the night here yeah he's
already well ahead of that eliminating
an important ingredient if black is
going to try to get some mating net here
so now up three pawns Carlsen the a pawn
is still around doesn't mind giving up
the a pawn because now you could just
rattle off a ton of moves two connected
pastors are they gonna play on I guess
so up five seconds but this is this is
plenty I'll see how he pushes the black
King back and slowly escorts the white
pawns 10 seconds or black
no no fancy steel matrix or anything you
know let's see evening out on the clock
oh there we go little fork no Stanley at
the king has one square black resigns
where are we at in the standings ali
reza 32 32 30 penguin 29 29 28 you have
to be you have to have 24 points if you
want to see page 1 carlson is in 22nd
place
catching next opponent Carlson is in
18th place nice strong center pressing
knoweth d5 some space for white as soon
as the queenside castle comes up notice
its c5 ensuring that the D file does not
get ripped open this is a sensitive
square and this point is weakened as
well look at the focus on this point
something's gonna happen here there's
going to be an accident on the e6 square
so now I'm just securing the King a
little bit more the King is without a
home the night just jumps on in there
not much to think about there it's just
just throw them in there even if you
drop upon the pieces are coming to life
possibilities to capture on e5 but now
you can't take the knight there's just
enough there's enough support for it
trying to weasel on in there light
square bishop exchange with me this
night would grow be much stronger it's
picking up upon Wow ok this is a dummy
piece what do you do with that bishop
staring off into space currently there's
a pin all right just Queen back
defending a - a little little jab there
on a - offering a rook exchange Queen
takes pawn rook up and over no trying to
take advantage of the pin can't take it
right away because this guy is pinned
King in the corner and then rook to B -
incoming here we go you got to get out
of the line of fire where to go King
pick a light square there it is no fans
yeah there is a discovery the rook it's
a
full rook no it's not not quite a full
truck but a queen versus rook and knight
and completely winning for white but no
no no no I shouldn't know black I'll be
able to make a lot of moves here I think
yeah has coordination this is not easy
now well Carlson's gonna lose this one
mmm perfect coordination here for black
really too easy to pre move too tricky
of a knight he's pushing through yeah a
resigned time for the doctor
I should mention okay penguin is in
first 34 with fire 32 it's fire macro
first prize is $3,000 second is 250
third is 175 175 top five gets something
next opponent another game against wgm I
thought they already played a game oh no
that was when penguin played okay I do
remember the name I was like wait a
second anyhow King side fiend keto
strong pawn on e5 a knight on f4 at some
point not just yet contesting the D file
there is this pin nope in the night
drifting into f4 would be nice I don't
see five as strong both Knights are
strong ah nice deflection there's Queen
takes on didn't want that
I'll Queen takes pawn Knight takes e4
King is very comfortable
Knight is a little bit annoying
provoking b3 some dark square weaknesses
now for this guy the bishop would like
to get activated so there's some focus
on d4 for sure every every piece is
functioning on d4 point white is up upon
however up a little bit on the on the
clock does not want to allow that
capture he's gonna get the pawn back
bishops try to get shut down with e5 hmm
okay yeah this was the opponent penguin
some
how came back and beat being really
really down on the clock home eight main
threats check check and then checkmate
careful now
okay this defense check it's close okay
is there light square blockade hmm let's
see this should be a draw but this is
gonna this is gonna be tough easier to
play for black got some some pawn
advances yeah and I could get an outside
passer and it should be it should be a
draw three point three
rat-race is pushing through actually
yeah Carlson will get this one two point
four is plenty Queen is gonna go wild
Carlson won that one is he on the first
page no 38 with fire penguin 34 Ollie
Reza 34 ARCA 50 another game York Meier
their fifth game a cattle and what do we
have here your buyer is a fan of the
Catalan alright open D file DN C files
much stronger Bishop for white better
structure for black king is not too
comfortable some coordination on e6 and
a lot of pressure so better structure
for black but better pieces for white
bishops on adjacent diagonals both rooks
on open or half open files but this is
getting a neutralized fast eventually
how do we get this King working okay
there's no longer great piece play for
white this is how the rook is brought to
life and it's now all of a sudden team
black who was better because of the
active rook slightly better King
position
trying to challenge g5 here I think you
may end up dropping that pond now look
stepping up he's gonna get some material
this rook is very active very very
active and another check his pawns gonna
fall with check white is better here
outside pass pawn as well this King is
very cozy down on time however white
would you rather be up upon up and down
ten seconds or Carlsen this pot is
really fast controlled upon with the
bishop and then get here is the plan
he's dropping the bishop boom big slip
very big slip now Carlsen is the better
side rook is ideally placed behind the
past pawn bishop is gluing that guy in
there and another yeah just really what
can you do
okay another game really fumbled there
towards the end and down on time time
pressure go Kirk on this is a
seventeen-year-old international master
don't don't be surprised if we see that
I turning to G into a gene not too long
from now very strong player streaming as
well right now so looking for the first
win as pawn has some great depth but I
don't know liability asset not sure
Knight takes Bishop takes it will be
picked up and I think we're gonna have
that tonight really doesn't have a good
square besides f6 so this guy is going
to fall and you know just a little bit
of regrouping uh-huh don't have to worry
about this main threat on g7 that's
defendant it's a little bit awkward
bishops out of the way this pawn is
ready to play with d4 mm-hmm
okay you know this is good for white got
the pawn back but now all the white
pieces are playing backward structure
Queen takes pawn getting the material
yeah
resign that's a full piece alright where
are we at in the standings penguin is in
first forty six with fire forty four ali
reza agra nation forty
where is carlson twenty first place
going into that gate in this last game
it's getting paired now he is in 15th
place not sure how many points Carlson
has I should I'll take a peek at page
two to see the how many points he has so
White's are really going all-in with
this launch on the kingside what's the
king going to do is a big question these
salmon was under fire mmm security okay
apparently g2 is gonna be the home this
tension stays on takes would be terrible
the night would just improve and the
structure would be ruined and if you try
and take out the night this Bishop would
be an excellent defender of f6 preparing
to open up the G file maybe a capture
capture right now now preserving the
bishop first dark square weaknesses
White has the bad bishop and the queen
is officially cooked that Queens a goner
and black knows it doesn't even have to
take it right away
ah now he takes it okay a little delay
there didn't need to take it so fast
then any fancy mates not quite rook
takes you can step up and take the
knight a little bit scary the bishop is
there to defend g4 yeah or was it or was
it because it takes there's rook takes
Queen hmm
oh the King could have maybe just played
back to a 6 d6
anyhow slightly behind Carlsen a little
bit scary inserting a check the King has
a new square all deflecting the King
away from the rook and addressing this
threat on the bishop before cashing in
having some material both rooks are
under fire yeah 10 seconds as well check
and there's no mating net against the
black king he's just giving some
material back to make it a little bit
simpler can function on the dark squares
Queen versus rook and Bishop take the
bishop in promote that's what we have
pick up the rook next and that's gonna
be resigned now they're gonna play out a
little bit more in just a few seconds
each making a few resignation Carlsen
wins where we act penguin is at 50
where's Carlsen 34 he is 16 points back
one hour 24 minutes remaining
let's see what we get this is this is a
lot of fun you know I'm I like to play
but I also like to watch I'm also I like
to play chess and I like to watch just
you know it's a lot of fun to watch oh
man
okay okay
yeah who would have thought I would've
thought okay some space for each side
space for Carlsen in the center space
for white on the Queen side black is
also going all in this little whenever I
see g4 I just think all you know so
weakening but but but but mmm
scary a little scary there for the black
Queen now this bishop isn't the greatest
in the world
okay he's weasel that weasel doubt
there's some there's some safety there
for or black here a little bit of a
clumsy rook you know clean stepping up
King up the rook wants to play Queen
takes pawn soon first rook activity rook
rook here may be Queen g3 and you don't
get this pawn back hmm
white is up some material they're going
too fast I don't have time to count I
don't know it just I don't know probably
a pun mate threat rooks are gonna be off
you can't do that because of check and
the Queen would fall not rook takes rook
black is on the back foot there has two
passers however that's a check this pawn
is really fast the bishop is there to
defend black is reminding white that
they also have passed pawn they owe
chop-chop this pawn would promote not so
fast check on the seventh or the second
now quite offering a queen exchange
white will promote white is winning
white is winning I think the king could
step up bishops will be exchanged as
Queen is ideally placed there are no
checks however wait wait wait wait wait
oh he's down on time too you're gonna
have me the King's getting mated King
here Queen there game over Carlsen goes
down one 22 remaining one hour 22 Ollie
Reza
Grandmaster ali reza with 56 points on
fire 56 52 48 39 one hour 22 minutes
remaining
where is Carlsen 34 points 16th place I
miss taffert the first few moves that's
what they were a b3 game you catch that
one ooh
why oh he's down a piece Oh a mouse slip
oh wait a second he dropped his queen oh
you mouse slipped
Bishop takes Queen Carlsen well I don't
know what you've played on probably okay
that's a big mouse lip you went in for a
fan's a quick Bishop g4 try to win the
Queen he Mouse lipped out okay
Carlson's down upon has a nice pot on e4
though not anymore a pin you can't take
counter pin alright a slight development
lead is there enough compensation here
for black white also has the bishop hair
let's not forget
and has consolidated white is simply
better here all pieces will soon be
playing nice squares for the bishop f1
this is a passer will get I'm get
running soon mmm he's gonna fall it
seems like he's gonna fall he's got a
push okay there goes a - that's a big
that's a big pond grab you can't take
here Queen b1 well maybe you could Queen
would go back but in the end I guess
this pond would fall strong Queen post
both sides with flight squares the
bishop patrols this diagonal very well
still supporting the past pawn on d6
where we had on the clock
five seconds back for black collar white
Carlsen is up on the clock yeah better
for white still Oh white is up three
pawns I don't know how you come back
from this one let's see out of the pin
no more pin here the bishop is
regrouping and the night is falling this
is this is a win here so have to watch
out for any any anything fancy here but
that's just not gonna happen
security the queen is just behind the
pawn he get marching the bishop is
always there to drop back on gg1
this is another approach I think he gave
up the pawn there for a second with that
push just a time edge for Carlsen that's
it oh okay now there isn't that it isn't
it isn't a perpetual the bishop drops
back yeah and now now that mate made on
g4 Carlsen goes down whoo plenty of
slip-ups here where are we at Carlson is
in with 36 16th place first place has 60
ali reza with fire only a few goose eggs
fantastic result thus far one hour
19 minutes remaining this is a big first
prize okay back in the ring Carlson I
missed the first few it looks like an
exchange caro-kann F pawn is active
connecting knight so central expansion
and the bishop only has one square okay
giving up the b-pawn just to have a file
to work with this is a case of opposite
sides castling action in the center I
like blacks position this space in the
center this pawn is rolling and what
does this Knight do a nice drop in the
corner in order for the the majors to
see along the B file black is better you
really need to get like all major pieces
functioning on this this point black is
so much faster in this position this
pawn can now be picked up the Queen is
there white is trying to get rid of it
but black says not so fast in a cash out
okay creating some imbalance hmm Center
just got ripped open his queen is now
very active Bishop is under fire the
knight isn't a pin things have just
turned with those last few moves
Queen is under fire oh there was even
Luke takes bishop first and then Knight
no there wasn't the knight had to move
first but now this is serious this is
winning threat of Knight takes Queen and
rook takes Bishop game over check me
white resigns 19th place for Carlsen one
hour 17 left Wow better kick it into a
higher gear I guess huh I don't know
he's quite a ways back and there are a
lot of people competing in those in the
front page top 10 a lot of players are
on fire they they they've been training
they've been training for this event
they they want that $3,000 this pawn is
very good
a connected passer this one not quite
connected white trying to connect it
both sides now with a connected pawn
this pawn well this Queen side is really
uh howdy how do you how do you get it
functioning Knight here might be a move
trying to get into c5 if I could draw an
arrow this is a nice pron chain yeah
there he's in he's in a noose don't want
to jump in he
that actually helps black to develop
black wants this night exchange this
night finally has a move how do you make
progress here as there there's just been
a queen exchange and a night exchange
okay there goes another pair nights
maybe take here and take the pawn no
wants to keep the youth material hanging
on to the a pond be careful now is when
you get the King working here we go just
just a little bit more of this Bishop
pressure here okay that's that's where
he goes for the pawn and now he's
looking for more pawns okay a pawn is
guarded by the bishop the bishop is
doing a good job controlling both the
pawn and the promotion there goes the C
pawn where we had on the clock a few
seconds up for Carlsen yeah and easy
from here up to pawns and this rook is
completely passive Carlson wins okay a
fast pairing hawk 20 feet a master where
we at in the standing 64 ollie Reza
slipped up 56 penguin with fire what is
this don't try this at home night eight
night h6 night f7 not something you see
every day staying out of the F pawns way
a mobile center the night could take up
a nice post in the center we do have
that excellent Black Knights now Han is
dropping on c4 very invasive piece there
is a pin can it be broken is why can't
ago pawn hunting white now doesn't get a
chance with rook to d1 offering a queen
exchange supersensible up a piece or
excuse me up upon and now a second
and he's on yeah there's no play here
structure kills both Bishop at night
passers another pawn ready to fall not
too long from now okay
64 with fire 60 64 no fire 60 with fire
penguin where is Carlsen 16th place
something like that okay I missed
something that's what I missed
Samael
kamil chess next opponent one hour 14
left this is a light square bishop type
position what do I mean by that each
side I think is trying to show that
their light square bishop is better than
the other ooh a little bit careful here
pressure on g7 now this is a threat
there's no longer a pin compromise
structure for white on the Queen side so
kind of like an extra epon okay there
goes the apon queen is going into pacman
mode I don't know is there anything
fancy happening over here and just
making sure one major pieces off the
board rook takes and Queen takes c4 this
rook is out of play if you can't really
coordinator here yeah just down material
and awkward pieces chosen the towel also
back on the clock quite a bit a resign
pretty fast when they're for Carlsen who
now steps up has 44 width fire is in
seventh place does not yet jump into a
game here we go nirvana 95 nirvana 95 um
their seventh game now a chair if
they're really from that location anyhow
we have some English is symmetrical
English I believe trying to get rid of
the the master bishop he's a gonner and
now getting on this weekend diagonal
immediately look at the focus on the
weak squares eliminate that key defender
of the dark squares and then pinpoint
those squares we might have resigned and
I think we're going that resign this is
a massive for what is it not hitting
he's not even gonna know what's that oh
yeah that's a nice way to do it I guess
you had your pick
that's one way to do it he's now up a
full piece and just swarming on in there
the Knights are hungry a little bit
clumsy right here this nights gonna get
flushed and the piece of get one back
and just take a pawn down yeah this is
nice
just wow that night just went out of
rampage
don't take the pun don't get to take the
pun you're gonna get mated the king is
cozy on III can't get it the king and
the night's gonna be beautiful on e4
this is a lot of ponds too ponds too
ponds too many and look at the clock as
well
30 seconds he's gonna he's gonna get
this one there's no no way to mess this
one up there goes the a pawn rook takes
pawn is going to a self pin one weak
point is now secure and there's nothing
to do this pawn waiting you see how fast
he is flying Oh tricky night game over
okay not yet in a game where is he yet
he's on the front page 48 with fire ali
reza 68 with fire Carlsen is a a full 20
points I don't know why fall he's 20
points back already crazy h pond huh
alright no open h file g4 space Space
Invader pawn here on h3 be surprised how
many different mating ideas are possible
with this pawn right here but white is
saying you know what I could push a pond
in your house too black king is without
a home and white is just trying to rip
things open when are these guys going to
play very soon could take the rook he's
a goner up the exchange Carlsen looking
for a discovery this rook is hanging any
Knight move and there's a punch are
there any good knight moves though
Carlson is uh I was gonna say working on
the knight moves that's it's a bad joke
bad joke is it even a joke oh there's a
blunder they're removing the defender of
h2 and going for a perpetual no he's
going for more maybe we're gonna have a
rook on g1 he's gonna be able to weave a
mate enough with these two Queen is
there defending g7 does he have anything
he's hoping
perpetual there's no perpetual this
night if he gets here
there isn't anything exciting okay now
you could even block on f8 oh there's a
pin you could block is there any checks
a couple checks you know just one check
one safe check black is winning this up
a piece now and up on the clock MSB to
is gonna get this one could I always
just give some material he's doing that
okay it is now even material but the
clock situation too tricky nice well
Carlson is now up upon don't blink how
many of you just blinked and miss them
white is up upon but way down on the
clock three point four seconds I
couldn't nights gun you get that phone
draw pull okay dodged a bullet there
he's no longer around fire fifty ali
reza saying this name quite a bit he's
Easy's top 68 64 57 56 Carlson is in
there with 50 is in a game he has just
fired up nirvana 95 again second time
this tournament so I guess a Benko yeah
no no no not at men caliber Dhoni
keeping the f-pawn flexible no knight on
f6 this this H pawn gets a little bit
excited and already try and eliminate a
master defender what's the White King
gonna do this rook has moved there is no
castling that's no illegal and there is
known Queen h6 b5 you don't need to
support this opposite sides castling
give me open files
that's what Carlsen wants Bishop takes
Queen here that's why there's some some
pause Queen h6 how you defending mate
that's how you're defending me Knight
here I guess the Queen starts to help
out this Knight is also under fire let's
not forget both sides the board are on
fire
okay I think black is their first ready
to take and then go here there's
follow-up checks on e4 no it's just may
threat on g2 all right Knight is a goner
and the Queen's he come off pawn takes
trying to rip things open the Queen's
can come off and in the end Carlsen is
up a piece to also take here and then go
for me that's that's efficient okay
resign mate right around the corner
matin one two okay Nirvana goes down
Carlsen up another two points fifty to
seventy ali reza penguin right on his
heels I came just finished 72 it's fire
alright missed the first few happens
from time to time okay Space Invader um
more space giving up the bishop hair
Carlsen does not want it does not want
to give black any squares to work with
and this majority is already set into
motion look at how fast four two three
four white on the kingside looking to
put pressure on this point excellent
post for the night and now it is
converted into a three to one for white
on the Queen side two two zero for black
in the center three two zero on the King
side it's a race position each side just
wants to push pawns get a queen okay not
so fast Bishop is there um how do you
get rid of the pond that's how you get
rid of the pond
this guy is secured by the bishop f2 is
falling and the knight is immediately
relocating not so fast here you could
take bishop takes you got to watch out
for something probably some knight move
there I couldn't quite see it okay now
you're now you're taking the rook is
guarding some squares from the night ah
fancy rook takes rook Knight takes rook
just trying to eliminate the blockade or
careful careful rook there's that so
this is trouble rook is a now ideally
placed
like not only up to ponds but perfect
post will probably have resign I guess
they're gonna play it out a little bit
more no stopping this pond okay I guess
he's gonna play this for now Carlson is
up a few seconds and a few points then
it goes another pond resign now okay
there's still one hour and five minutes
remaining in this one where we at ali
reza is taking a bathroom break I
imagine 72 no fire 6664 and Carlson is
back in the game ARCA 50 number six six
place Carlson ARCA ninth place what is
this this is a French I believe
Rubinstein I missed the first few some
coordination on g2 both bishops now
pointing at the White King multiple
pieces pointing at the White King that's
not so significant upon really trying to
hammer away against Issa --cs
Wow everything is being coordinated on
e6 something fancy might happen on h2
this bishops eyes are open let's see if
this happens okay a little bit backward
development for white now already
crashed through on h2
giving up the exchange this Bishop
becomes an absolute monster all black
pieces are now playing and they're all
pointing at the white king these guys
are spectators
okay giving up the exchange taking the
exchange white now there's a problem
here and here Queen takes h3 g2 is under
fire you can pin the night and then
threaten this or go right in for that oh
right there is that a resign all the
black pieces just came to life there on
the towards the white king fast paring
jungle Viking no idea who this is okay a
Sicilian d4 recapturing on d4 with the
Queen not a king night I could draw
working with the e4 the E and F on e and
F
you know launch the Jeep on ya once more
this this idea see it time and time
again don't be afraid to give up pawns
in these cases of opposite sides
castling if that pawn will grant you an
open file or half open file towards the
enemy King here we go that's a serious
pawn these guys are now ripped to shreds
Cosi Cosi Cosi king over here white is
down a piece though hmm this would just
bring the bishop to life I'll be able to
do something clean in here no no not too
fast the bishop is covering h3 now
trying to trying to sneak on in h5 pivot
careful this rook right white is down a
piece but this extra and this extra
piece that black has one of the pieces
is officially in the corner for forever
no longer down a piece by the way and
black is probably gonna resign yep
resign turn the towel jungle Viking goes
down Carlson goes up for 62 it's fire
only back twelve points one hour two
minutes to go ali reza remains in first
penguin on his heels with 70 and fire
penguin on board is getting hit with the
dutch wow the dutch don't see that
played by carlson and it's great okay
bishop hair for the penguin not the
clever tactic but fail the regular the
regular penguin penguin had many fooled
the last titled arena prepping e4 anna
watch black has to be very careful about
this is unopposed bishop so now can't
get too excited with the e pawn f4 is
super important to control efore would
give this knight a wonderful square
black is down upon but has excellent
pieces and now the pieces are sneaking
in towards the king
how to break this down the night is
flushed back and g3 is now secured d5 is
being undermined the center is ripped
open something's going to happen on f4
there are many pieces converging here
now he wants the f4 square and when is
up on the clock and I believe doing well
objectively yeah this is better for
white I don't think there's anything
fancy here that what is what is that
about
okay problem here why does the better
side double up on the G file h3 was hit
that was a mate threat Queen defends
there might even be a queen sacrifice
g5 rook takes pawn Queen takes rook is
possible Queen takes rook no it's not no
no you get hit with the mate got a
responsibility Queen that's why there
was maybe a little bit of a pause there
still can't take problem here on the
dark squares for Carlsen 10 seconds to
sort it out not even Oh prepare to run
yeah he's preparing to run is he gonna
run is probably gonna give the check he
already pre moved that he was expecting
this he's doing this no matter what oh
there goes the Queen oh she's that oh
the bishop was there defending penguins
gonna win this one wait you see him fly
oh not a point one is gonna come off the
clock promise you I promise not point
one oh I'm wrong he should win this one
though he should be able to win this one
he is so fast
oh no maybe maybe I was looking at the
wrong clock I might have been right now
it was that two point one anyhow he's
just so fast
it's so fast oh man okay Carlsen goes
down Carlsen goes down and Owen Baba
Ramdev next opponent okay yeah these
these guys are going to not make it easy
they all warm to 3k fourth place third
place in the tournament standings that
was a wild game opposite color Bishop
position and you know hopping in dark
square weaknesses for the black King and
yeah when you see this fish up an
absolute nightmare no I'm gonna go pawn
grabbing Queens are now off
and here someday maybe
what's this night up to it he's a he's a
struggling piece killer pawn and I wants
to be here here but what's its path how
do you how do you do that tough too
tough to do that okay the night found a
spot but white is now just having an
active rook an active King and hand up
upon these guys are all gonna fall one
by one black throws in the towel where
are we at ali reza 79 with fire penguin
with 74 carlson is at every chess
players favorite number how many points
back 15 points back york meyer again
another dutch on board not the first
time also we're seeing this little this
a little maneuver night h6 to f7 hmm a
little bit of a weird piece okay so in
their first game Gorga meyer had a good
position but ended up in some serious
time pressure dropped some some pieces
back carlson is eliminating the light
square bishop master defender the king
side the night is repositioning there
was a discovered attack against the
queen and now black is up upon what is
this knight do okay a little bit of a
hesitation there i guess because it does
give up some squares getting upon their
discovered attack on e6 offering a queen
exchange his pawn is backward this queen
is now very active tonight isn't a pin
this is a strong piece for white White's
best piece queen on d5 only one square
for the queen a two is under fire this
night is an excellent defender for the
black king white is up white is better
here excellent queen she's really gluing
everything together really really
wonderful piece rook can't do any better
even material but pawn quality is his
King in this position yeah
down on clock how to push this pawn
through I guess here in here on is
trying to put a dent the night is just
taking a white wants to keep the
structure as is I don't think he's there
in time just safeguard this diagonal
yeah a Queen immediately here and it
could give some material it's just one
check just one check no no follow-up
okay I resigned Carlson goes down again
ali reza the number one guy in the
tournament fantastic result thus far 55
minutes remaining
what is with this night h3 9 h3 night
night h6 stuff it definitely makes for
some interesting structures that's for
sure I'll get to see that too often okay
I think this is this is good for white a
struggling night this often happens when
one side has a little bit of space and
now upon is picked up and this guy has
just torn open that f-pawn really did a
number on blacks King side this is at
night isn't a pin this happened York my
er did this to Carlson's knight in the
previous game Queen on d5 pinning a
knight clean pinning the night here if I
could draw problems here on h6 what's
the what's the scoop here could take
that where's the mate Wow very nice not
able to get the rook the bishop
interferes with that idea black is
better here black is up a piece
a little bit annoying pin the king is
flying any good follow-up checks you
could go here yes no we're there two
ways to block they're still as a pin but
there's a way out
mmm imbalance though it's a rat race
pawns are fast how do you stop them yeah
they're really really fast in a sack one
this guy's fast to haul more Queens
around the board checker oneis who knows
what's gonna happen
Wow and I'll quick this one turned I
have no idea how this one finishes just
uh just just watch
oh man he had that one Olly Reza had
that one Queen takes Queen a mouse lifts
what is with these wire players Mouse
slipping minor pieces capturing
Carlson's Queen we saw that earlier
Bishop takes Queen was tried instead
Bishop Bishop e2 he's so close you're
just one square away just one square
away it happens too much fun settle down
settle down
alright that's a weak guy King Carlsen
get rid of that guy we're gonna see
doesn't seem like it this Knight is a
monster oh okay so you have to act in
some other position otherwise you're
just crawling up to land ball crawling
up into a ball and waiting not a good
strategy ever so black wants the Queen's
off sensing danger with the thorn on h6
stopping h6 Queen f8 first time playing
against this player clean is ready to
play or the rook is ready to play the
Queen could play to g7 defending the
mate it's a it's very good for black on
the Queen side now some action in the
center Queens off you know this would be
good for black to have the Queen's off
then you could pinpoint these weak
squares
he's weak pawns a fork Wow
winsome material can you get on this
diagonal first the knight is secure
there's a threat of a pin
that's defended rook g6 rook is under
fire oh we missed that it's gonna be
game over check around something better
I guess he had his pick Queen his gun
I'm gonna resign plenty of time for
Carlson resigned it is where we have the
standings ali reza 8178 penguin 68 68 68
68 Carlson 6th 13 points back 51 minutes
to go Baba Ramdev again 5th game I
believe in this tournament a Benoni on
board in one of the bananas I think we
had the night going here so we're not
gonna have repetition now okay but there
is some cost connected with this
variation the D pawn is now a goner
White's D pawn is passed black is up
time wise thou development wise all
pieces playing a majority here on the
Queen side for Carlsen and it gets
pushing Knight takes super invasive this
Knight wants to play E for two to one
for Carlsen on the Queen side think you
could even afford a queen exchange there
you want it okay hmm it's gonna fool
careful careful careful check I guess
the king is ready to run gonna pick up a
pawn first hmm
ready for at least a perpetual idea
Knight takes bouncing back and forth f6
h7 this King cannot flee oh there's also
that move as well the queen is a goner
does he have more he's trying to
calculate some more that's why there's a
pause I don't know the queen is also
under fire Knight takes Queen Knight
takes Queen I didn't realize the knight
was hitting the Queen there okay the
knight will be there just in time with
the pawn runs mm the knight is sectioned
off the King is now going to be a
to help out defending against the
passers white is better here white is
down just a couple seconds but course
better pawns on dark squares this will
be a tough one to come back from yeah
Harlan just gets rolling mm-hmm
probably push yeah can the bishop stop
both pawns no pushing through it's a win
for Team white don't drop your queen no
ok Carlsen resigned not easy
oh and he's in pause mode bathroom break
83 with fire ali reza seventy eight
seventy two seventy all right while he
is in pause mode let's check out i can't
i can't resist you got to check out the
penguin when you have a chance let's see
what the penguin is up to penguin good
guy that penguin what is what is he up
to
mmm g4 14 white this is a monster night
not now but not a permanent home though
brought into question the f-pawn is
around f5 in queenside castle i imagine
we'll be there the safe ground for team
black is now that time yes it is giving
me square backup hmm this pond has some
aggressive intentions going up to f3
Carlson is still not in the game hmm
tough to assess this one okay a little
fork threat huh ideally you want to have
this this pawn move in at some point
this will be the safe home for the King
both sides have pretty good pieces now
there's some some material there and it
doesn't want to take that route just yet
you you could take it no you don't have
to know that the rook can't move you
drop the bishop
it recognizes that just once to get out
of this pin may be preparing to take
without a recapture and a check he wants
the full piece
he wants more the white says now you're
gonna give me a passed pawn d e4 pawn
ePHI pawn is now passed under 10 seconds
for white not a good thing to do be down
on the clock against the penguin yeah so
fast I guess this one's gonna be a time
when yeah 1.7 isn't it's just not
happening mm-hmm yeah that's a classic
bullet thing probably pre moving that
expecting a Queen move
okay back to carlson who is in a game
not an OP is a colored bishop position
okay this should be is there a way to
put it no there wouldn't have been away
as soon as the pawn goes here white does
that and there wouldn't be a way to
enter that would be a drawn King and
pawn endgame not anymore this is an
important tempo King here yeah no this
pawn is just falling or this pot is just
running I should say this pawn is
falling white knows it and throws in the
towel
okay standings this is where we're at 85
80 74 Carlsen 70
all right are we gonna get in game 45
minutes remaining how many points is he
back
85 he's back 15 okay Don Matteo 85
running with the Queen rook pawn space
just wants to give up the piece huh
Bishop for Knight exchange as good
coordination structure and Bishop a
little bit of an uncomfortable pin yeah
this pawn on a 3 provides a nice square
for black pieces on b4 especially at
night if we could get there or even a
bishop in this case can be quite strong
white is breaking in the center however
and now winning some material we have to
go into an awkward pin there wasn't
really good squares these black pieces
are really knifing into the white camp
pawn is pushing his past he's out of a
pin now didn't mean to do that continues
to march white is up upon very very deep
and he cannot take the pawn because of
Knight f6 mm a little bit uncomfortable
there how is that working
okay he's oh that was sweet
I just had I just had to shut up there
for a couple seconds and just appreciate
what just happened
don't try to compensate I what just
happened just sometimes you have to say
you know that was sweet
but what just happened there I couldn't
really put into words it was just sweet
that was a nice tactic Knight f6 still
in that position love it okay there's
still some work ahead because this
bishop glues everything together you
know the king the king is there stopping
this advance but you stop to be a little
bit careful however okay not now this
King is an excellent block hater
probably have just a time win
but back and forth the king should get
oh okay there was an opportunity to take
there the king was blocking the bishops
view and now outside passes this is a
draw is is he gonna be able to know the
this guy seems to be fast enough bill
gahl fifty moves this is uh this is a
draw probably have repetition soon no
doubt on time oh I think he was trying
to maybe move here here get in the
corner
probably best is to get in the corner
Carlsen just one on time of course an
objective draw there 72 it's fire this
is this is important he's back fourteen
he does have fire win here with full
would get four Baba Ramdev again is his
his most frequent opponent I believe
three to two
oh yeah their sixth game in this
tournament okay let's see what we get
here isolated pawn a bishop that's going
to struggle no not now on has moved a
pin on one okay Santa has been wiped out
symmetrical structure same color bishops
Queen is on a very nice square observing
b7 and f7 ff7 is super sensitive
what's that idea just inconvenience the
yeah in Khomeini's the king and then
play to f4 a little finesse white is
white is a tic better because already
has a flight square in this major piece
Pacific position and already trying to
take advantage of that ripped a stroke
mate would follow so now each has a
flight square white slightly better
slightly more active but you know what
this Queen is is fantastic and this rook
is just not going to budge this should
be a draw objectively especially if
these guys are exchanged Carlson knows
this wants to keep a little bit or
action and the clean side keep it
relevant this pawn will fall no now we
just stared the clocks
and he just stared the clocks carlson is
up five seconds and being very
aggressive now g4 what is that about the
base point is covered
there's always there always seems to be
one piece there securing it trying to
weave a mate
there's the rook up and oh that pawn
could have been captured miss that huh
missed it or didn't want it going for me
now no Queens are now off King and pawn
endgame Carlson's up seven seconds
this should be a draw black will be able
to manage a draw here this will be a
drop a draw on board 40 minutes to go in
the tournament ali reza still on top
only by a point penguin hot on his heels
74 carlson is back 13 points
Paco next opponent another streamer
grandmaster Bale a Sicilian on board d4
or not no no d4 for white black wants
the space okay two minor pieces the
knight is recapturing looking for a new
square huh what was the trick there I
think there would have been Rick takes
if the Queen moved rook takes Knight
okay so minor piece and balance a little
bit of space here on his out of the line
of fire
where's his home where's the Knights
home I'm gonna find out maybe it may be
f6 is the home and he's gonna get
flushed to f6 not a bad square a flat
you attack the bishop counter punch and
now defending I probably should have
inserted h6 first White has just grabbed
a little bit of space f6 or excuse me f5
is a nice square if the bishop isn't
around controlling that it would throw a
punch Knight f5 would be met with h5
what black wants to stop that idea first
and only then jump into f5 if the bishop
is not around d3 forget about it d3
anyhow sacking the exchange and now the
rook is wild
even material and this should be a
careful you can't allow a pawn takes
pawn no no black is black is winning
this because I think however you slice
it though they're those last few moves
black would be able to acquire a outside
past pawn if the King moved there would
have been a or if I capture King
captures and then push here this guy is
better than this guy in this ending this
guy is past though well something
happened over here something happened
over here while I was staring over here
okay the Queen's are on board
Karlsson is better even on the clock the
Queen is gluing everything together
black is up two pounds the Queen is an
excellent defender this arrangement
right here there are no good checks no
good checks Queen on f3 the King is
slipping in trying to trying to get on
up in there get on up in there okay the
Queen's are gone oh another oh there was
an opportunity to win the Queen there Oh
Carlsen one okay with less than a second
38 minutes remaining and does not have
fire hasn't had a four in quite a bit 76
still 13 points back macro next opponent
advanced CARICOM I almost said advanced
French not quite okay Carlson got rid of
his bad bishop is happy probably and
yeah g4 possibly it's committal okay
opposite sides castling pressure here
and here mm problems center is now
collapsing the rook is a goner' light is
better mate threats this might be a
resign
no Queen is back to defend I missed that
Queen takes Knight and get mated
just deflecting the majors away from
this file white is still up the exchange
and now piling up on the preparing a
battery on the C file yeah yeah this is
this is gonna be hard one to hold now
this guy has passed no past pawns for
black easy for white I believe check and
then get this guy rolling it's gonna get
rolling huh just push for resign Carlsen
goes down whoo ali reza 91 penguin 88
catching 82 carlson is 15 points back no
fire back in the game against his
favorite opponent a classical NIMS oh I
guess Baba Ramdev pin action in the
center this is how he's apparently gonna
get out of the pin connect the Knights
and then get the Queen out pressure on
c3 winning upon bounce at the moment
this pawn is bound to fall capture the
bishop and then capture here capture the
bishop and then capture here that what I
said okay now this pawn isn't going
anywhere
Bishop is supergluing that pawn in there
okay
I imagine the Knights will be exchanged
and we're working with opposite color
bishops okay and that's what we have in
between er in-betweener mmm maybe that's
why we had this I think if Rick takes
pawn here could have been annoying so
opposites opposite sides castling
opposite bishops opposite color bishops
and even material okay each side with a
flight square that's good and some
secure pieces for both sides don't know
let's see how this one plays out also
even on the clock controlling one of the
dark squares in the center and it's just
it's solid for both sides here tough to
make progress might see a lot of
shuffling this Bishop will be challenged
even if this Bishop was here you'd see
f6f-3
I'm upon dropped there can this guy get
rolling careful ooh okay the Queen was
there just in time to defend that main
threat Queens are now forced off this is
this is an objective draw Carlson is
down on time you got definite a definite
draw here objectively and Bishop can
always just go here defend these to the
king is responsible for stopping this
one let's see how many moves these guys
can pull off is it gonna sneak in
something like this he's gonna try to
run over here really fast and pick up
this pawn repetition a draw on board I
think he only gets a point for that
let's see yeah you just got a point 77
penguin is in first 92 with fire that's
huge
fire look it you don't see fire okay
another game another GM battle
half-opened e-file light playing in the
center
efore f4 pawns capture all up with f5 or
d5 if the knight moves the bishop would
fall black powering away at these pieces
that are on the open file all right
balanced material no black is up upon
this is the patent this is the extra Oh
was that a mouse lip no not quite no no
it's not a mouse lip Turner's restored
pressure against what just happened
there well the Queen felt there was a
skewer there rook to e1 if the Queen
move the rook would fall so instead of
being down a full rook black wants it
Queen versus rook but either either
however you slice it white is white has
a queen versus a rook go into a pin or
drop here Bishop back if to cover the
base points there is some coordination
here
actually mike has a little bit more has
a bishop in rook Bishop and rook versus
Queen is the imbalance trying to get at
this point this is sensitive in the
target this point now he's gonna press
here with the bee for at some stage
before now and Bishop takes pawn however
still getting a past prawn have to be
careful Skye is tricky oh this should be
a fortress this is a fortress the king
stays here in the rook goes there this
this is gonna be a tough one for Carlsen
to hold black will be able to make a lot
of moves fast
the nycos here let's see oh just like
that just like that yeah black had
coordination there Carlsen goes down
again plenty of slips and this one is in
9th place thinking around this point in
leech has titled arena 4 he really
stepped on the gas he's back 16 it needs
to do that right now he's to win against
his favorite opponent game 8 in English
on board against a Baba Ramdev hope I'm
pronouncing that one right with how many
times they've been paired up okay
Carlson's down upon has a little bit of
space some security for c4 this Knight
moves there's a fork
careful Knight this pawn is a little bit
weird on c7 a little bit backward no
idea how to assess this one
it's Knight controlling d6 what is
trying to get at that point bishop air
advantage for Carlsen can't take the
knight because of a discovery the Queen
would fall d6 might put you into an
uncomfortable pin so says no thanks
putting pressure on blacks best piece
exchange Bishop's no Bishop Bishop takes
Bishop there would have been Knight
takes Knight ruining White's structure
and only then a recapture okay Bishop on
d5 this pond is uh is in a pin just one
upon the bishop and patrols this
diagonal Queen takes Knight Queen takes
Knight down on the clock by a few
seconds Carlsen trying to shoo the Queen
away from defense it's not happening
challenging the knight black is better
here on the clock objectively monster
knight on e5 safer King what if I missed
a lot of good things for black he could
could give up the strong night for the
bishop if you want okay
offering the Queen exchange just one
pond restricts these to watch out for
something sneaky I have something sneaky
at some stage when Carlson's down and
even more on the clock you might have
something like a for B for gonna fall
well there was an opportunity to take
the bishop you can't stop the pond and
every sign up eight seconds as well a
Baba Ramdev with the W Carlsen goes down
again and is just barely on the first
page 77 back-to-back losses penguin is
up there 96 with fire 19 point lead
Jesse Pinkman next opponent Knight h6
into f7 I think this this 3k first prize
maybe for the first time going to
somebody else other than Carlsen
we'll see
um yeah Queens off the exchange no Queen
takes Queen there be a recapture with
check there wouldn't be time for this
fork okay
black has the pieces working even
material Knights are exchanged what am I
talking about
even material don't you see a knight
here White has a knight and black
doesn't have a knight it's not even
material Carson is down material he's
missing a knight he really wants a
knight right now and he's just not
around and there's no no advantage on
the clock either any big trouble
King takes skewer this one's this one's
not gonna go in blacks favor I just
don't see how you work some magic here
where's the magic King's flushed back
King is now becoming active and get out
of pins there's a there's a check
possibly check right now light square
bishop exchange in the night here no
activity allowed rook controlling the
base points the Knights ready to hop on
in 16 seconds 15 seconds nothing to do
Carlson throws in the towel 27 minutes
remaining and Carlson is no longer on
page one
neither is oper Wow
penguin meanwhile is now at triple
digits 100 with fire back in a game
Carlson he needs to make a run and fast
like right now he's in 11th place he
needs to like win oh I think to catch
penguin who is on fire macros the
opponent look at their score four to
four hmm you know they were macro one
there there one game in this tournament
clean versus rook in night position it
was okay not the the healthiest of
structure on the kingside bishop here we
met with a timely a very timely Knight
f5 hitting the bishop hitting the Queen
white is still trying though
prepared to sacrifice and does this is a
monster bishop black knows it needs to
challenge it right away
does Oh Mouse live what's with these
Mouse lips they're just one square away
another that's the third Mouse lip I'm
promised you Queen takes pawn was the
idea
okay Carlsen got a win just then he
needed that 100 penguin still in that
game where are we at okay another game
nother game nother game needs to get on
fire another win here and he'd get two
points needs to get on fire needs to get
fours is this where he's gonna make a
run we're gonna see good good position
let's look his Carlsen down at night now
he's not down tonight in this cam I
gotta cool gotta go back to basics count
minor pieces before pawns okay even
material no Carlson's up upon he's up
upon this is maybe a little bit
sensitive careful careful careful Bishop
back Queen takes F to counter punch
against this rook doesn't have to react
just yet okay now there's pins there's
defense Queen is excellent on b5 ah just
winning some material now Carlson is up
a bishop okay and is saving the bishop
with this Queen exchange and we'll be
getting this one he's going to get this
w with 24 minutes remaining in every
sign or play on how we looking in the
standings okay we resign quick look at
the standings penguin slipped up okay
100 where is Carlsen 81 he is back 19
points with 24 minutes to go but I
believe has fire yeah think he won his
last his last two games they're going so
fast it's tough to keep track but okay
he's going with something saw
none of this night age six to f7
business he's maybe taken it serious now
okay that maybe this is is this serious
Carlson now we're gonna we're gonna find
out he's up upon these guys are getting
rolling
I gotta go counter punch both bishops
under fire
Dexter 29 is the opponent only took me
30 seconds to realize who the opponent
was this Bishop can be brought to life
targeting d3 the knight just fell
Carlson's up a piece and piling up on
the pinned Bishop quick resigner
now he's just he's up a piece and these
exchanges to bishops versus one quick
resign and boom seventh place 85 with
fire 15 points back it is possible it is
possible 23 minutes to go let's see
we're gonna get a pairing no time for
bathroom breaks getting the ring he's in
the ring against the pack leader
the slippery one penguin gee I am one
was he thinking about you for Best Buy
test penguins gonna throw the French
maybe or go something main line the
French loves the Rubenstein we're gonna
have a Rubenstein chopper Oney okay it's
a game of it's a piece play position c5
at some point okay directed at
controlling the c5 break it seems with
these last couple games Carlson is
playing a lot more controlled a lot more
serious
I get the feeling no no it just as g4 is
played right a lot more a lot more
control g4 on board ok blackton get in
the a its Remo giving up the exchange
has a nice home king security
very strong for white a master knight on
c6 his under control at the moment
Bishop fights off some nice squares and
he just went pawn hunting okay and this
Bishop might struggle some this pawn is
fast bishops gonna help out control it
bishops very good here the King the very
strong piece but the bishop in a
coordinate very well to stop this this
rook and this pawn might start to bolt
okay first gluing in the knight here
here comes the a pawn how we doing on
the clock 28 to 24 mm careful careful
careful you have time to pick that pawn
up okay careful there was a threat
against the rook there is no check the
bishop controls that is this a pawn
gonna bolt and we pressure here rook
here he's kind he's on the
counter-attack he's prepared to give up
the bishop for this pawn for sure
actually how do you even do that you
have to give up the rook for the pawn
penguin is better here this is a huge
game you have to watch out for the a1
square the King can he slip away the
King is slipping away a knight on c6
would be fantastic and I think he's
going to get that I don't know but he
could get the King he's slipping away
now he's giving up some material just to
get the knight very good decision yeah
and now this pawn is is flying yep
penguins gonna get this one I don't know
I don't know how to call it I don't know
how to call this one I've got the Queen
Tarim no Carlson's down on time oh
that's a huge win he didn't get 4 for
that but penguin now has fire Carlsen
does not 85 that's a huge win if penguin
goes on to win it that game you just saw
right there might have been the one to
do it
that might have been the 3k Game one
okay the back in the game would you miss
that who nineteen minutes ago so
asked down to the wire just a second for
each side
wow what a time scramble that one was
bullet that's bullet for you
back rank issue need a new square rugby
eight is a threat
oh there's multiple threats back rank
and also this and night there okay very
nice found a way to save the peace it
cost a lot of time who's better
I don't know this pond is scary night
here and then get running
he's picking this guy up ok Carlson is
now better hmm and this pond be saved
yes
Carlson is better better King primary
thing mmm he's pushing through now where
is he now these pawns are very very
strong push King here does that work no
King here there's Bishop takes pawn very
important it would be Bishop takes pawn
our Bishop takes Bishop excuse me this
is better for team black of course up to
pieces how do you how do you how do you
win this one Carlsen you have to push oh
boy is it the wrister it's the wrong
colored Bishop is he gonna be able to
burn these seconds off of the watch oh I
couldn't as he dropped a bishop he
dropped the bishop Carlsen won that one
oh man that's luck a little bit a little
a little bit of luck there 87 Carlsen
still back 21 with 17 minutes to go how
many more games can you get in
maybe I'll eight or nine games his
favorite opponent of the tournament game
number nine he is also in ninth place
Wow okay a benoni on board 17 and change
can Carlson 5 Pete you won the first
four Leach has titled arenas white is
better here ending this 'if I've
break-in is this a liability
what's this night up to I guess he's
gonna capture here and after the smoke
clears white is white is just better
comparing the night's a little bit of
space some simplification clean on d7
you know I couldn't get away with taking
that pond no he's flushing the rookies
winning some material there is no sack
because this this piece is defended
they takes f6 there is no Rick takes
rook it's up the exchange rook is under
fire defended queen is defending on okay
taking up a post on on this square soon
first getting out of the reach of the
night yeah that was that was actually
pretty important Knight f6 would have
followed so king g7 the Queen is now
active just went on a rampage picked up
a couple pawns wants to get on this
diagonal question the king excellent
piece flush the night away the Knights
not going too far away that was pretty
strong here but like has coordination in
a clear plan ready to push through
trying to get it this square I guess so
could use the rook as a defender are
there any hmm are there any could follow
chicken yeah this is a problem Knight f6
is a problem here's met with this Knight
f6 is a mate threat it's not just a fork
that's that's may threaten giving up the
Queen just to get rid of that master
killer
efore up on time though Carlsen there is
at least perpetual for white you wanna
probably take it well there's no move
huh connection issue no there is a move
he sidestepped the checks
he has opportunity to win he's getting
the Queen sneaky move a sneaky bullet
move he's gonna be able to get this one
whoa where are we at 15 minutes to go
and a checkmate on board where are we at
he has 89 he has fire he needs to win
out penguin slipped up he's at 112
carlson is back a lot 23 points is a lot
to overcome
okay needs to win out for sure and even
if he does I don't know if it's still
still possible space for white Queens
are gon d5 is strong Knight Hopson let's
see how black addresses this space
disadvantage b2 is under fire okay
that's defended c4 is under fire it's
night under control trying to take
advantage of the pinned rook c4 is
secure now could take the knight oh he
missed he missed that the knight is
covering that square pretty fast win
which puts him up to six place he got a
four first four and a little bit
ninety-three with fire macro next
opponent slight edge in there match
score five to four Queen d6 offering a
quick Queen exchange I've seen him do
this multiple times
okay the knight isn't a pin he was ready
to drop in she's taking out he's gonna
he's gonna he's gonna go let it go a
little bit greedy there grab the pawn
and then try and consolidate that's an
that's an important that's not just any
pawn no C pawn means this square is a
reliable home for the night there he
goes he's gonna prepare to castle on
what direction no Castle what cat which
way you go and Carlsen neither I don't
know I don't want a castle this is my
home f7
oh he's castled by hand I love it
just make me eat my words he is so in
the end he he
a castled kingside just by hand around
about castle that's all okay you have to
be careful look at look at this square
rook g1 how are you defending this idea
yeah the bishop has to give the to give
the King a square but is there is this
in move no not quite but this square
certainly comes to mind
okay the dark square bishop is a goner
we're gonna plant here yes I think black
is better having consolidate he's gonna
win a rook he's gonna get this one white
resigns Carlsen up for on back-to-back
fours you have to go back maybe good
half-hour to see back-to-back four is 97
with fire top guy does not have fire 114
penguin ali reza on his heels with fire
oh man
okay opera 21 to one you're not gonna
see this type of score by ya 21 to 1
against opera is huge this is such a
fantastic player okay let's see Queen
side castles bishop hair Carlson has
some space doesn't want a knight trade
wants to flush the night away with c4
some activity with the rook c4 on board
careful now Knight here no that could be
met with that so the nights are
inconvenienced for sure
this might be a little bit annoying and
that's secure now okay white is the
better side having having a nice central
presence Oh check and the rook would
fall opera just resigned another pretty
quick win 11 minutes to go no time to
check the standings last game Jesse
Pinkman 1 yeah that was the game where I
didn't realize Carlson was up a piece or
excuse me down a piece let's see if I
could count in this game that's all I'm
looking to do in this game looking to
improve
can I count in this game let's see
Knights eyeing up c5 it's ruled out
Knights being a pest f6 is now secure
the structure controls these two
doesn't want to see see for it doesn't
want upon doesn't want to ruin the the
structure here on the queenside space
each side with some space and now this
is targeted black is better here this is
a fantastic night defending upon putting
pressure on another black is very active
the white rooks are passive and now
black is up upon its night this were
gonna be trapped does this trap the rook
has to give no it's not trapped go there
this real kind of it find at home and I
cash out now g3 or b3 okay trying to
remove the night even on the clock watch
the night away is to find a new home and
now this pawn falls with what neither
doesn't want it just yet watching here
you take with the night okay
two minor pieces versus the rook
position better for Carlson defend here
take this pawn and you give this guy up
okay okay now at night now you take the
pawn you give a check and you run here
huh
look at the clock look at the clock and
he's getting that very valuable outside
passed pawn check rook takes pawn
there'd be a fork
careful now check know he's mopping up
this passer a clock situation who knows
how okay that was a big sequence right
there should be able to get a lot of oh
there's there's a fork he's gonna be
able to get this one pre move with the
king pre move with the bishop just don't
don't drop one of the miners oh he
didn't get that one that's huge he lost
on time no I didn't lose on time but
it's a draw he he didn't have any time
on the clock but opponent did not have
enough material where are we at in the
standings really quick 103 to 18 he's
back 15 with 8 minutes and change to go
who he really needed to win that one
just was not fast enough with the mouse
I don't know you're only getting four
games in maybe five
James oh he really needed to get that w
w is not there 44 seconds call it even
on the clock oh I don't know I don't
think there's a path to victory to
getting first place he's in fifth it's
not just penguin there are some other
guys really competing for that first
spot that's how you know it's super
strong Carlson being in fifth place
after an hour and 50 minutes of play
this is an excellent Bishop that does
not want to budge just reinforce that
point okay no he's taking trying to get
into these light squares keeping the
Queen honest on a four a five on board
going pawn hunting doesn't want to go
defensive trying to damage the kingside
structure okay what's black going to do
offer a queen exchange Queens off cannot
stop this pawn it's not looking good
objectively or white here and just has a
little bit more on the clock look at
this King you're gonna step up ooh
really can you eat too okay some checks
he's getting this pawn hoppers really
fast you could exchange Queens and then
get the King over here he went for the
draw I think that's gonna do it you're
not catching these top guys and in fact
ali reza is now in first carlson no fire
104 14 back with six minutes to go
wow he really needed that that win when
it was the two miners versus the king
and well needed to win this this past
game it's gonna take a couple minutes to
even get on fire who okay let's see
f-pawn gonna roll b7 is under fire this
is a weak square can a knight get there
that would be invasive rook as well
would be nice the knight on d4 however
can challenge a piece on c6 he's going
in there right now punch the Queen
looking at f4 keep the Queen's on no
Queen was very active trying to keep the
Queen's on the a pawn Falls and this guy
is super strong I think white is better
no I missed that move up the exchange
now Carlson's up the exchange this these
rooks aren't so great though on the
defensive you know light squares an
excellent grip over the light squares
what's this bishop up to he's getting
he's getting exchanged back karlsen's
going down in this game I believe and
it's a struggle down on the clock this
guy's been flying 32 seconds remaining
King will be there in time to stop this
pawn sacrifice on this square knight in
the corner you could take here you're
there in time if you want it
Knight in the corner excellent find
still have you could still do that oh no
no no no there was the threat of Bishop
check sneaky and there was once more
this idea of a check and the bishop is
actually there in time to stop this
little tactic and is he gonna be able to
sneak through here he managed to stop
that tactical idea which is very
impressive are we doing here is this
pawn gonna bolt how do you stop the pawn
are you gonna be able to stop the pond
and he's getting he's just gonna get
take the pawn let's see it's gonna be a
draw it's not getting this one Carlsen
actually loses that one it's not going
to Carlsen Leach has titled arena will
be going to somebody else that
somebody's either ali reza with
20 or penguin 1:18 with fire carlson 104
not enough time to make up that gap back
16 with four minutes to go you're only
getting two games in oper next opponent
who all right I think I don't want to
watch that game I want to see this game
this is more interesting
let's see these final two games this is
this is maybe for all the marbles I
don't know where ali reza one penguin
two and penguins going to win this one
two bishops and you can pre move this
one Oh penguin might be in the lead
after this game and I'm actually gonna
sneak over to penguin and this final
let's let's see where they're at
penguin has a lead that what that might
have been the game 1:22 it's fire if
penguin wins his next game he's gonna
win titled arena 5 this is a huge game
let's see how this one finishes I need I
needed to jump away from Carlsen and see
penguin can he do it a win here and he
will get it he'll be up a cool four with
under three minutes to go let's see if
he can do it
queenie to defending the bishop
excellent position for penguin material
okay he's down upon but he has excellent
pieces and i don't know how how black
gets hot this definitely keep the
Queen's on an uncomfortable pin maybe
maybe something like this a 7 is under
fire the Knights looking to reposition
d6 square rook ripped d6 as well as
possible rook d6 on board can't go too
far Queen the knight would fall is this
going to phone Knight takes pawn there
is this the knight would be in a pin
this is excellent this is excellent for
white is he going to get the
when he's up on the clock oh the rook
the rook the rook has to move here and
block the check was under fire taking
advantage of the pin counter pin 25
seconds each Queen takes Knight rook
takes rook sneaky okay there's a check
another check here no good for penguin
just by a little bit is he gonna get
this one you get the Queen's off oh did
he did he mail slip there oh there's a
perpetual is it a perpetual it's a
perpetual oh where we got 124 that
should still be good enough for it
because Ollie Reza slipped up I think
that's going to do it
124 120
this one more game by the penguin I
could get in the game there we go
this right here I believe is going to be
the winner up for with less than a
minute to go in the tournament nobody
has fire and a quick draw right there
that's actually gonna seal it for sure
let's look at the tournament 125 unless
ali reza berserks his last game let's
see this one he didn't berserk he's not
going to be able to get three this
titled arena Leach has titled arena five
is going to the slippery one penguin
GIM won $3,000 let's see let's see the
number two guys final game here wow what
an event
what any event all right down the
exchange
yeah probably resigned her here the
little pumpkin is going to win yes
alright and with that there's absolutely
no seconds on the clock
final standings with this tournament
didn't see the last couple of games by
Carlson but it was too interesting to
see ali reza versus penguin towards the
end there wow what a close call in first
penguin walks away with the 3k in second
ali reza and then we have arc of 50
wizard 98 not familiar with the wizard
and this guy who i'm just i don't know
how to pronounce all GM's
one I am and I am that will probably
soon be a GM certainly GM strength I
imagine in the end doctor drunken Stein
Carlson finishing in seventh place with
109 points 125 120 to 130 112-111 top 5
all with some cash Carlson in the end
was back 16 points Wow let's see all the
pages here page 2 so in total 307
participants in this titled arena this
is page 2 page 3 I mean these are all
fantastic like this MSB to is up on the
top page and Leach has titled arena for
another page just going through them all
here you can quickly see any any Fay
it's of yours there's there's a lot of
pages to go through so just want to see
where we're at
boy this is this is a lot of fun this is
a tournament that's a lot of fun to play
in and observe oh just going through
them all about the halfway point and I
think right around this stage we have
mostly those who just play for a handful
of games and then say no thanks I'd
rather do something else
yeah non players okay in the end Wow
congrats to the penguin certainly made
it close in the last title dureena
titled arena 4 and yeah was able to to
win this one fantastic result how many
games did he get in there 67 games 67 66
69 how many how many dcarlson get in 59
hmm oh he had a slow start to those
early connection issues and I still even
even even without that still had some
issues some games this was a lot of fun
you